[موسيقى]
أنت
رجل الساعة على الأرجح في الأسبوع
وربما العام
وتصدرت عناوين الصحف الحديثة خلال الأيام القليلة الماضية
عندما أعلنت أن اللقاح
الذي كنت تعمل عليه
أه لديه 94.5 معدل فاعلية
واثق من أن هذا سيقودنا
إلى نهاية الوباء
جيدًا نهاية الوباء أه يمكن
على الأقل البدء بتوافر لقاح
ولكن هناك طرق جيدة لنقطعها
لأننا نحتاج إلى التأكد من أن اللقاح قد
تم الموافقة عليه أولاً  من
وجهة نظر تنظيمية ،
ثم يتم توزيعها على كل من
سيأخذ واحدًا ، علينا التأكد من أن
الجمهور لديه ثقة
في أخذ اللقاح وبعد ذلك
بمرور الوقت
بشكل جماعي لن يكون للفيروس
مكان يذهب إليه
ومن ثم يمكننا أن ننظر إلى الوراء و  أقول إن
الوباء قد تم التعامل معه ولكنني
أعتقد أن الثقة كلمة قوية أنا
واثق من أنه سيكون هناك لقاحات
يجب أن تترجم إلى النهاية ولكن
لدينا بعض العمل
لنقوم به كم من الوقت تعتقد أنه سيستغرقنا
قبل أن نقضي على
الطمع 19. مرة أخرى ، أعتقد أن هناك الكثير من
التكهنات حول ذلك ،
وكذلك بالطبع أيضًا يدخل
في السياسة لأن هذا قد أثر
على جميع السكان على هذا الكوكب
ويريد الناس أن يختفي هذا
ويريدون العودة إلى  طبيعي ولكن بالطبع
سيكون ذلك من وظائف العلم
والسلوك الفعلي
وإلى الحد الذي
يتبنى فيه الناس بالفعل التدابير الصحيحة كل من اللقاحات
وتدابير السلامة الأخرى ، أعتقد أنه يمكن أن يكون
شيئًا
سيتقلص بالتأكيد في وقت ما في أواخر عام 2021
وربما في عام 2022  أي شيء أسرع من ذلك
هو سيناريو صعودي
وأنا أفضل عدم التخطيط للاتجاه الصعودي
كمجتمع
لأن نتيجة
الخطأ في ذلك هي المزيد من الوفيات
المعاناة ، لذا فأنا في
الجانب الحذر
وأريد فقط أن أفعل  الأشياء الصحيحة
وبعد ذلك ستعتني بنفسها ،
لذا سيأخذني هذا قليلاً إلى ما
قاله ممثل شركة Pfizer بالأمس
أنه يتوقع أن يكون صيف 2021
صيفًا عاديًا ،
هل تختلف معهم؟  أنت تعرف أم
لا أعرف في أي سياق قالوا
ذلك
وأكثر من ذلك ، لذلك لا أعرف كيف يمكنهم أن
يعرفوا أنه يبدو لي أكثر
مثل الأمل والطموح وأعتقد
أنه من الجيد أن يكون لدينا آمال كبيرة جدًا
عندما  بدأنا كنا أول
شركة تبدأ في تطوير هذا
اللقاح وعندما بدأنا
في مارس كنا نأمل أن يكون لدينا
لقاح جاهز للمسبح بحلول
نهاية العام
ولكن الصبي لم يكن هذا هو النتيجة الوحيدة الممكنة
لذلك الآمال جيدة لأنه
يحفز  الناس
ولكن الآمال قد تكون سيئة أيضًا لأن
الناس يبدأون في وضع
الخطط ويصابون بخيبة أمل لذلك أعتقد أن
صيف
2021 للقضاء أو دعنا نقول على الأقل
الصيف الطبيعي لعام 2021
هو نظرة متفائلة للغاية
مرة أخرى ليس بسبب اللقاح ولكن
بسبب  معدل التبني
ومعدل التوافر الذي سيستغرق
بعض الوقت ،
هل يمكنك بمصطلحات الشخص العادي
وبكلمات بسيطة جدًا أن
ترشدنا خلال عملية البحث عن
اللقاح.
روس هو
ما يسمى بالضعف مما يعني
أنه ليس الفيروس بالكامل
ولكنه تضرر إذا فعلت ذلك
، لذلك لا يهددك بشدة
أن تمنحه للناس ويهاجمه جهاز المناعة
أو أنه جزء من الفيروس
صنعه الناس  في المختبرات
وتم إعطاؤها للأشخاص ، هذان هما
طريقتان للقاحات
وهذا ما يستغرق عدة سنوات
لتطويره في حالة
Moderna ، فقد ابتكرنا منذ حوالي 10 سنوات تقنية تسمى messenger rna أو mrna
والتي تستخدم الجزيئات الموجودة في
خلايانا هذه  جزيئات المعلومات
التي تنسخ الحمض النووي وتصنع بروتينًا
، وباستخدام تلك التكنولوجيا الجديدة ،
يمكننا تقديم
المعلومات
المطلوبة بسرعة كبيرة في لقاحاتنا لجسم الشخص الذي يحصل
على
اللقاح لصنع بروتين من
الفيروس الذي تعرفه الصور  التي تراها
على الفيروس الذي يبدو وكأنه
زخرفة عيد الميلاد نوعًا ما
مع كل المسامير التي
تشبه المسامير الموجودة على السطح
لديك القدرة الآن
على جعل جسدك يصنع أولئك الذين
ليس لديهم
أي فيروس دون أي خطر ، حيث
يخبر البروتين أن جهاز المناعة
يأتي ويحصل علي وعندما
يتعلم الجهاز المناعي كيفية القيام بذلك
عندما يظهر الفيروس الحقيقي يكون
جاهزًا للهجوم
والهجوم  تحييد هذه الطريقة
التي يعمل بها اللقاح الذي تصنعه Moderna
الآن من حيث التطوير ، كان علينا
اختباره أولاً لمعرفة السلامة لدى الأشخاص ،
وهو ما فعلناه من مارس إلى مايو وقد
أعلنا عن نتائجنا في
مايو ، ثم اضطررنا إلى توسيعه ليشمل 30000
شخص
في  حصل نصفهم على اللقاح ،
وحصل نصفهم على اللقاح الوهمي ، وهو ما
يعني في الأساس عدم
وجود لقاح ، ثم قطعنا مقارنةً
في كل مجموعة بعدد
المصابين
بالمرض وحتى الآن عندما أبلغنا عن بياناتنا ،
أصيب حوالي 95 شخصًا بالمرض  في تجربتنا التي أجريت على
90 شخصًا لم يحصلوا على
اللقاح ،
كان هناك خمسة أشخاص تلقوا اللقاح ولم
يكن أي من هؤلاء الخمسة
مصابًا بالطمع الشديد ، وكان هناك 11 من أصل
90 مصابًا بفيروس كوفيد -19
على الجانب الآخر.  ما
أعطانا القدرة على إعلان النتائج
لأن هذا
مهم جدًا من الناحية الإحصائية وإلى متى سيكون
الأشخاص الذين يتلقون
اللقاح محصنين ضده وهذا شيء
نحتاج إلى إعادته كل عام مثل لقاح الإنفلونزا
على سبيل المثال أو
فاتورة واحدة مؤكد أنها من بين
الأشياء الجديدة مع هذا
الفيروس الذي لم نسمع به من
قبل قبل عام هو أننا لا نعرف أن
هناك أشياء كثيرة لا نعرفها
ولا نعرف كيف يؤثر الفيروس
على  رئة القلب والأعضاء العديدة الأخرى
الدماغ
نحن أيضًا لا نعرف كيف سيفعل الجهاز المناعي
في حمايتنا على المدى الطويل
، لم يكن كافياً على المدى الطويل
لمعرفة ما إذا كان سيحمينا
ولكننا سنجد قريبًا  خرجنا
لأن لدينا بالفعل أشخاصًا في النسخة
التجريبية الأرخص منذ
يوليو بالطبع بحلول يناير ، سنكون قادرين على
إخبارك ما إذا كان يحمي لمدة ستة
أشهر
ونحن في العام المقبل في الصيف ، سنفعل ذلك
إذا كان ديفيد يحمي لمدة عام واحد ،
لأن لدينا 30000 من whic  سنتبع 15000 من اللقاح وسنرى ما إذا كانت الحماية تتدهور إذا سألت عن تخميني أقول إن هناك فرصة جيدة جدًا للحصول على حماية لمدة ستة إلى 12 شهرًا على الأقل وهناك أيضًا فرصة أنه قد تكون سنوات عديدة من الحماية لا نعرفها حتى الآن ، فقد كانت شركة Pfizer والحديثة هم المتسابقون الأوائل في السباق ضد Covet 19. ومع ذلك ، ما نعرفه الآن هو أن التخزين والتجميد وظروف التبريد في Moderna أسهل والأكثر ملاءمة ، أود أن أقول كيف ترى أن هذا قد يؤثر على البيع على المدى الطويل وتعتقد أن هذا شيء سيكون لصالح الشركة لأنه من الأسهل على البلدان الأخرى تخزينه وتوزيعه حسن المظهر ، أحد الأشياء التي سأقولها هو أنه عندما تتعامل مع جائحة ، فإن قوى السوق العادية التي تجعلك تعرف جهاز iPhone الخاص بك أفضل من هاتف Samsung الخاص بشخص آخر لا تنطبق لأننا نحتاج إلى كل هذا
يمكننا الحصول على لقاح e ، لذا فإن أول
شيء سأقوله
هو أنك تعرف أنه مع كل
اللقاحات التي ستكون متاحة سيكون
لها بعض المزايا والعيوب ،
لكنني أظن في السنة الأولى
خلال الوباء
أن هذا لن يكون عاملًا كبيرًا
بالتأكيد  سيساعد ذلك
في التوزيع والحداثة ،
يجب أن تعرف أيضًا جمهورك يجب أن
يعرف أن Moderna
قد طورت واختبرت سابقًا
10 لقاحات مختلفة على البشر وأن جميع
الأشخاص الآخرين
الذين يستخدمون هذا النوع من التكنولوجيا في
mrna لم يختبروا أي
لقاحات وهكذا  لقد أتيحت لنا الفرصة على مر السنين
لتحسين تقنيتنا
حتى نتمكن من تجنب
التجميد العميق لـ -70
درجة يمكن تخزين لقاحنا في
درجة حرارة أقل من 20 درجة
من ظروف التجميد العادية
ويمكن الاحتفاظ بها لمدة شهر
في الثلاجة في منزلك  في المنزل ، لن
يكون لديك في منزلك ، فلن تحتاج إليه
ولكن
يمكنك القيام بذلك في أي
ثلاجة عادية ويمكن الاحتفاظ بها بالخارج
على الطاولة
لمدة 12 ساعة نتيجة
سنوات عديدة من التحسينات والتحسينات ،
كيف سيساعد ذلك في مساعدة الأشخاص
الموجودين في الخطوط الأمامية لإدارة
اللقاح ، سيساعد الحكومات على تحديد كيفية
الحصول عليه في كل مكان
بسرعة بدلاً من جعل الأشخاص يأتون إلى
موقع مركزي ،
لذلك هناك العديد من الأشياء
ميزة
ولكن في نهاية اليوم لا أريد
أن أرسل إشارة إلى أن لقاحًا واحدًا
سيفوز بحادث آخر أم لا
لأننا نحتاج إلى كل اللقاح الذي يمكننا
الحصول عليه ، حيث سيحتاج مليارات الأشخاص
إلى هذا حقًا
وأي واحد منهم  سنكون قادرين
على إنتاج 500 مليون مليار جرعة
ربما في الأشهر الـ 12 المقبلة نحتاج إلى
المزيد
، نعم وماذا عن الأشياء الأخرى التي
كنا نعرفها عند سماعنا عن
اللقاح الصيني ، فاللقاح الروسي
هناك لقاحات يتم إجراؤها
تم تطويره في الصين وروسيا
التي تستخدم تقنية مختلفة
تمامًا والتي تستخدم فيروسًا حيًا
ليس فيروس كورونا بل فيروسًا آخر
يسمى الفيروس الغدي
والذي يقوم بعد ذلك بتوصيل التعليمات  لكي
يتمكن الجسم
من صنع نفس
بروتين السنبلة الذي نستخدمه
، إنه شيء يتم
اختباره ، وهناك بعض النتائج الأولية التي
سيكون السؤال هو أنه يمكن للجميع
الحصول
على نفس النوع من الحماية ، لذا ما
يهم هو الفعالية
و  القيمة الوقائية
للقاح وكذلك السلامة ، لذلك
نحن ننتظر النتائج من astrazeneca ،
فهم زملائنا نعرفهم
جيدًا جدًا ،
لقد دخلنا معهم في شراكة مع Moderna
ومشاريع أخرى ، لذلك نتمنى لهم التوفيق ونتمنى لهم
النجاح والتوفيق  بالطبع ، نتمنى أيضًا
للصينيين والروس الذين يمتلكون
تقنيات متشابهة جدًا فيما بينهم
النجاح أيضًا ومرة أخرى ليس ال
مر لطيفًا بل هو حر
يًا يحتاجه العالم ، إنه وضع غي
عادي للغاية حي
تعرف مرة أخرى إذا كان الناس يت
ورون جوعًا ، فأ
ت تعرف شخصًا ما  لن يكون طعام شخص
ما أفضل بكثير من
تذوق الآخرين ،
فأنت تريد فقط الحصول عليه ،
وهذه هي الطريقة التي يشعر بها أنه
سيكون  الراحة لمعرفة المدة التي تستغرقها هذه
اللقاحات
كما طلبت سابقًا ، أعتقد أنه إذا كان هناك اختلاف
اخترناه الجرعات والنهج الذي
اعتقدنا أنه سيعطينا
أقصى قدر من الحماية ، لذلك أعتقد أن
جميع الخيارات التي اتخذناها
يجب أن تمنحنا أفضل فرصة في  ليس
اللقاح الأكثر فاعلية على الرغم من أنه
فعال للغاية بشكل واضح
لأنني أعتقد أن الآخرين يمكنهم الوصول إلى هناك ولكن
ليس لدي الآن بيانات لإثبات ذلك ولكن
الجرعة التي نستخدمها
أعلى بكثير ويجب أن
تنتج
استجابة مناعية أقوى وبالتالي  نأمل
أن تكون الحماية الدائمة التي لم يتم إثباتها بعد نوفار قرارًا واعًا
للإعلان عن نتائج
الدراسات والنتائج التي تفيد بأن كل ذلك
بعد انتخابات الولايات المتحدة ينظر
في حالتنا إذا كان أي شخص يتتبع متى
فعلنا ما فعلناه
فسوف تدرك ذلك  لقد علمنا بالفعل منذ فترة طويلة
أنه لن يكون لدينا بيانات
قبل الانتخابات
وقد أوضحنا ذلك
وأعلننا في الواقع عن
أحد الأشياء التي فعلناها مع شربيل في
هناك قلق متزايد من أن
التجارب السريرية لا
تمثل التركيبة
السكانية للسكان
في تنوع معين ، ولذا
قد تدرك أو لا تدرك أنه في
الصيف
قمنا بإبطاء تجربتنا لتشمل المزيد
من الأشخاص ذوي البشرة الملونة و  لدينا الآن 37
من تجربتنا التي تمثل الأشخاص ذوي
الأصول الأسبانية السود وما إلى
ذلك ، وكان ذلك قرارًا حذرًا
لا علاقة له بالانتخاب الذي كان
له علاقة بحقيقة أننا بحاجة إلى
استعادة
الثقة في لقاح تم
اختباره في  الأشخاص
المناسبون أيضًا كبار السن الذين
يتأثرون بهذا ،
لذلك في حالتنا ليس على الإطلاق أه حقًا
بشكل عام
تمت تغطية سياسات هذا
بشكل عام في وسائل الإعلام
وكان هناك الكثير من الجدل
الذي تعرفه إذا كان بإمكانك تخيل
اليوم في Moderna
، يعمل مئات الأشخاص بشكل أساسي
على جعل اللقاح
يختبر اللقاح
يحضر الأجيال القادمة ، وهناك
القليل من الوقت للسياسة
كما تعتقد  أن الانتقال المعقد
في رئاسة الولايات المتحدة
قد يعقد توزيع
اللقاح في مرحلة لاحقة ،
فلا ينبغي أن أتمنى ألا يحدث ذلك ، لكن
ربما والسبب في ذلك هو أننا
نعيش في أوقات غريبة ويبدو
كل شيء.
مفتوح للجدل ونوع محتمل
من الاضطراب ، على سبيل المثال ، إذا
أصبحت العلاقات
بين الدولة الفيدرالية
والحكام
متوترة وإذا فعل بعض الحكام
شيئًا وفعلت مجموعة أخرى من الحكام
شيئًا آخر ،
فأنا متأكد من أن ذلك سيعقد الأمور و
يبدو أن هذا بدوره له
دوافع سياسية إلى حد ما ، وآمل
في نهاية اليوم
أنه من حيث علاقته باللقاح ، لا
يلمس أحد أي جانب
من جوانب ذلك ويعترض طريقه ، لكننا بالطبع
حذرين للغاية ونتأكد
من وجود  الكثير من التواصل
والكثير من التخطيط
والتنسيق وهذا أفضل ما
يمكننا فعله
ولكن هنا لنتحدث أكثر قليلاً عن
التوزيع ، كيف سيتم ذلك
وفقًا للمعايير
وما هو المهم  ستحصل ريس على اللقاح
أولاً
بشكل جيد ، لذا فإن هذا سؤال جيد
داخل الولايات المتحدة وداخل
البلدان الأخرى ، ستحدد الحكومات المحلية
أن تسلسل التوزيع على
الأقل في الولايات المتحدة
واضح تمامًا أنه عند الحصول على إذن الاستخدام الطارئ ، يكون
الأشخاص الأكثر ضعفًا والأكثر عرضة للخطر
من المرجح أن يحصل عليها العاملون في الرعاية الصحية
أولاً
، وبعد ذلك ستكون هناك موجة تلو الأخرى من
شأنها أن توسعها بحيث يكون ما تم
الإعلان عنه هو أنه بحلول
الربع الثاني من العام ، يكون الأمل هو
الحصول على لقاح كافٍ لتلقيح أي شخص يرغب
في الحصول على
اللقاح.  على الأقل ،
فإن الهدف المتمثل في أن تسرع العملية تسرع
الكيان الذي تم إنشاؤه للتعامل مع كل
هذا كما هو مذكور علنًا
، ونحن بالتأكيد سنقوم بدورنا
لجعل ذلك
ممكنًا في البلدان الأخرى الآن من حيث
الوصول من حيث تأمينها.
عقد صفقات
مع الموردين
أه إذا نظرت إلى astrazeneca بعض
شركات الأدوية الكبيرة
هذه قد قدمت إمدادًا كبيرًا جدًا
الصفقات حتى قبل
أن يكون اللقاح معروفًا بعمله ، وبعض
البلدان يحتاجون عدة مرات تقريبًا
للتأكد من أنهم يحصلون عليه
بسرعة كبيرة
، لم تؤمن البلدان الأخرى
الإمدادات بعد أو تحاول تأمين
الإمدادات
من أماكن مختلفة ، هل تعرف
نصيحتي بشكل عام  هو
أنه إذا قمت بالفعل بإجراء العمليات الحسابية ، فإن
توفير المال على هذا اللقاح
يعد خطأ في التقدير لأننا ننفق
المزيد من الأموال على الاختبارات التشخيصية في اليوم
أكثر مما ننفقه
على ما سننفقه على اللقاح واللقاح
إلى حد ما يتخلص من
ضرورة إجراء
الاختبارات اليومية ، لذلك من ناحية التكلفة ، تعلم أن
الأشخاص قد ألقوا أرقامًا تتراوح ما
بين
عشرة إلى ثلاثين دولارًا للجرعة إلى أربعين
دولارًا للجرعة ،
هذه الأرقام حتى مع جرعتين يمكن
مقارنتها باختبارات تشخيصية واحدة ،
لذا أعتقد ما هو  سيحدث هو أن
الناس سيؤمنون
الإمدادات على المستوى الحكومي
ويوزعونها على مستوى
قرارات وزارات الصحة الخاصة بهم وبعد
ذلك سنوفرها  ومن ثم المساعدة في
التيقظ الدوائي مما يعني
تتبع ما يحدث عندما
يأخذ الناس اللقاح والتأكد من أنه
آمن
تمامًا ويتم قياسه عندما
تعتقد أن الناس في الشرق الأوسط مثلي
، لنفترض أن الحالات ذات الأولوية
ستكون قادرة على الحصول على اللقاح  في
الوقت القريب ، أعلم أنك لا تعرف أنه لا
يوجد شيء ثابت هنا
وهناك العديد من المعايير
فقط أعطني تقريري وأعتقد
مرة أخرى أنني لا أعرف صفقات التوريد التي
أبرمتها كل دولة أو تقوم بها
مرة أخرى ستعرف ذلك بشكل أفضل  لكن
بشكل عام ، أعتقد أن
الإمدادات الواسعة ستصبح متاحة
بدءًا
من الربع الثاني من الربع الثالث من العام المقبل ، لذا أود أن أقول إنه
إذا كان الناس قد حصلوا على إمدادات مضمونة ، فأنا
أتوقع من الربع الثاني إلى الثالث من العام المقبل
أن يبدأ هذا العرض في التدفق مرة أخرى.
مائة بالمائة
في اليوم الأول ولكنه سيبدأ في التدفق ،
أود تبديل التروس قليلاً والانتقال
من اللقاح ومهنتك المهنية
إلى شخصيتك أه إلهامك  قصة g
وهي أيضًا مثيرة للإعجاب جدًا ،
أنت لبناني أرميني ، لقد
خرجت من لبنان عندما كان عمرك 13 عامًا ، هل هذا
صحيح ،
نعم لقد غادرت في عام 1975 مع
عائلتي ولماذا تركت مرة أخرى ، ثم
انظر جيدًا لقد كان لدينا
شاعرًا  الحياة في بيروت كانت كل
ذكرياتي في طفولتي
بيروت مكانًا رائعًا
لأكون فيه المجتمع جسديًا
وكل ما يتعلق به أه ولكن
للأسف كلما كان لديك
أماكن شاعرية أه تنشأ الخلافات
وكل بضع سنوات يكون هناك
نوع من
الصراع وفي  1975 الحرب الأهلية في لبنان
أه اندلعت وفي البداية اعتقدنا جميعًا
أنها شيء عابر
ولكن بحلول منتصف العام
أصبح واضحًا أن هذا قد يكون
صراعًا طويل الأمد جدًا ووالدي
أه و  قررت الأم أنه مع وجود
ثلاثة أشقاء ، لا ينبغي لنا حقًا
المخاطرة بالبقاء هناك
لسنوات عديدة عندما تكون المدارس مغلقة
وتكون الحياة صعبة ،
لذلك اتخذنا القرار بشكل أساسي صعبًا
عليك.  ترك قرار gh كل شيء وراءه ، وقد
ترك عقله التجاري
للانتقال إلى مونتريال وكنت ممتنًا
لأن كندا استقبلتنا بالفعل
كلاجئين سياسيين أساسًا
تركنا البلاد في ظل
ظروف شبيهة
بالحرب ولكن لكن كثيرًا من السنوات التكوينية
في  في بيروت
وجزء كبير من ثقافتي هو لبناني ،
ما الذي احتفظت به من تلك الثقافة أه
مثلما لا أعلم أخبرني أكثر قليلاً
هل زرت لبنان
مؤخرًا ما نوع الذكريات التي
أخبرتني بها قليلاً عن ذلك  نعم ،
أعلم أنه أمر ممتع ، إنه أمر مضحك ، نحن
عائلة صغيرة كما تعلمون لأن الأرمينيين
تم ذبح العديد من العائلات الأرمينية
لدرجة
أن الأشخاص الناجين الوحيدون هم
10 20 شخصًا ، وأعتقد أنه ربما يكون هناك 20
شخصًا يُطلق عليهم اسم feyen في
العالم
أه لقد كانوا عائلة أكبر بكثير
ولذا تعلم أننا ولدنا
من جديد بشكل أساسي في بيروت
عائلة أمي والدي
لم يولد والدي في بيروت ، لقد ولد في
بلغاريا وهاجر عندما كان
الشيوعي  جاء النظام
حتى تعرف أنه إذا عدت إلى أي شخص
أرميني ، فربما يكون لكل
لبناني قصة عن سبب مطاردته
من مكان إلى آخر ،
كنا نتاج ذلك ، لكنك تعلم أن
الأرمينيين في لبنان هم مزيج
من الثقافتين.  وهناك
نسخة لبنانية مميزة جدًا من
الأرمينية حيث ترى الجوادافير في حياتهم
ترى التفاؤل الذي تراه الميل
للاحتفال بالطيبة ، كل هذه الأشياء أه
تقريبًا أقول
أه إلى أقصى حد في لبنان هذا  كيف
نشأت
أه حتى تعرف أن تلك كانت
ذكريات جميلة جدًا وحقيقة أننا
هاجرنا وحقيقة أننا اضطررنا إلى
ترك كل ذلك وراءنا
ربما غرس شعورًا بمحاولة
الاحتفاظ بقطعة منها
في ما أفعله في المستقبل  وهكذا
تعلم أن هناك الكثير من الأشياء التي
استمرت في أن تكون
جزءًا من حياتي سواء كانت موسيقى
معظم أصدقائي
في بوسطن هم
أرمينيون لبنانيون أو أرمنيون سوريون
بالطبع لدي أيضًا  أصدقاء لبنانيون
حتى تعرف أن الأمر مجرد معرفة أكثر ،
أود أن أقول
أه ثم البقية كما ذكرت
عن
ثقافة الصمود هذه التي تأتي من التفاؤل المطلق
مع كل الاضطرابات السياسية التي تحدث
في لبنان والانهيار الاقتصادي
الذي أنا متأكد من ذلك.  تعرف
هل ترى ضوءًا في نهاية
النفق ،
فأنا لست على دراية
بالوضع السياسي اللبناني ، لكنني على
دراية بأنه كان من الصعب
جدًا التوصل إلى اتفاق على أي شيء ،
وللأسف أعتقد أن هذا
هو الأكبر  بالمناسبة ،
هذه المشكلة هي الحالة المتزايدة
في الولايات المتحدة ، يتم وضعها بشكل متزايد في
بلد آخر بذلت الكثير من
الجهد فيه وهو أرمينيا
، وبالتالي يبدو أن هناك فترة
يصعب فيها الاتفاق على
أه ربما على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي  يتسبب في ذلك
لأن هناك أشخاصًا
يسمعون مرارًا وتكرارًا ما يؤمنون به
لأنهم محاطون
بالأصوات التي يؤمنون
بها ولذا يعتقدون أنهم على حق فجأة
يعارضون عندما كنتم كان الجميع أقلية لأنهم لم يكن لديهم أي فكرة عن من يتفق معهم احتياجات لبنان والعديد من البلدان الأخرى للتحول تحتاج إلى أشخاص يختارون الوجهات على الاتجاهات وأعتقد أن هذا سيمنحني المزيد من الثقة وليس فقط التفاؤل بأننا يمكن أن نكون على مسار أفضل وكل ما أقوله لكم ينطبق بالتساوي على أماكن أخرى ، أي رسالة إلى السياسيين اللبنانيين ، هل يمكن للمستقبل أن يضع الناس أولاً ويضع الرغبة في الانتخاب أه وراء ذلك لأنه إذا فعل الجميع ذلك. ستكون النتيجة أفضل ، أعلم أنه من الصعب جدًا القيام بذلك لأنه إذا لم يتم انتخابك فلن يكون لديك صوت ولكن إذا تم انتخابك بقول كل ما يتطلبه الأمر ، فهذه مشكلة أيضًا ، لذا أعتقد أن على الجميع أن في وقت يخرج منه جائحة بشكل خاص ، ما يقلقني هو أن هذا الوباء قد تعرض لأزمة جسدية في العام الأول ، حيث سيكون لديه أزمة اقتصادية دائمة لفترة طويلة ، وهي مستمرة.  لأخذ
قيادة لا مثيل لها حتى
ننسحب منها ،
أسافر حقًا بنفس قدر التفاؤل كما نحن جميعًا
ثقافيًا العديد منا
أه فكرة أننا
سنعود إلى الوضع الطبيعي
هو بحد ذاته شيء يمكنك سؤاله ،
أعتقد أننا  ستكون في حالة جديدة
غير طبيعية
لفترة من الوقت حتى تظهر حالة طبيعية جديدة
، فلن يحدث ذلك بين عشية وضحاها ،
ولن يحدث بلقاح
سيحدث إن
مجتمعي يتكيف مع الصدمة التي مررنا بها للتو
ما زلت
مستمرة وكواحد من رواد الأعمال الرائدين
من الجذور العربية ، ما هي رسالة
الأمل التي قد
تحملها للشباب والشابات العرب الذين يشاهدوننا
اليوم
ينظرون منذ جيل مضى أو
الأشخاص الذين يطمحون للحصول على وظائف يحصلون على وظائف
وكان ذلك الأفضل  يمكنك القيام
بذلك بالطبع
، لطالما كانت روح المبادرة موجودة في الشرق الأوسط من
حيث صلتها بالتجارة التي كان والدي يعمل
فيها ،
وأن رجل الأعمال في الشرق الأوسط
غالبًا ما كان يُنظر إليه على أنه  خاصة
في
لبنان بالطبع في البلدان الأخرى حيث
توجد موارد طبيعية ، الأمر
مختلف قليلاً
ولكن لديك الآن جيل جديد
بالتأكيد جيل بعد جيل
يتوفر له
مهنة جديدة تمامًا تسمى
ريادة
الأعمال وريادة الأعمال كما تعلمون
جذر  الكلمة هي أن تقوم
بشيء ما ،
لذا خذ زمام المبادرة وأعتقد أنه يمكنك القيام بذلك
وتكون على استعداد للفشل
ولكن بعد ذلك يجب أن يجدك النجاح
وأعتقد أن هذه مهنة جديدة تمامًا
وليست هواية وليست وسيلة لكسب المال
بسرعة ولكن مهنة وأعتقد
أن الشباب
في الشرق الأوسط يمكنهم بالتأكيد
تكريس
أنفسهم للتعلم بشكل أفضل في ممارسته
واستخدامه في نهاية المطاف
كتذكرة اقتصادية لإنشاء مجتمع أفضل ،
ثم ما تفعله بالمكافآت التي
تكسبها هو مقياس
لنوعك الأخلاقي  ومثلك
وأعتقد أن أحد الأشياء الأخرى هو أن
جميع رواد الأعمال الذين
يستفيدون من التوافر  من هذا
النهج الجديد يجب أن يعود
ويساعد البلدان والثقافات التي ينتمون إليها
حتى تتاح الفرصة للآخرين
، وبالتأكيد في حالتي ، كنت أفعل
ذلك منذ فترة من
الوقت بالطبع أرمينيا أيضًا
بلد محتاج
وبعد الاتحاد السوفيتي قضيت
وقتًا طويلاً في محاولة المساعدة
هناك ورأيت
كيف يمكن للشباب الذين يختارون هذا المسار
أن يغيروا البلد بشكل أساسي
ولذا أود أن أشجع الناس على
عدم التردد لأنك تعلم أن الابتكار
هو  شكل من أشكال الهجرة هو
هجرة وفكر
وأحد الأشياء التي يمكن أن
تفعلها البلدان هو في الواقع اختيار الهجرة
دون مغادرة البلد ، والطريقة الوحيدة
التي يمكنك القيام بها هي إذا قمت بتغيير
البلد
بحيث يمكنك إما الذهاب إلى بلد آخر
أو التغيير  بلدك حتى يصبح
بلدًا آخر ،
لذا لا يتعين عليك تركه.
الهجرة
هي أداة يمكنك استخدامها
للتقدم في
كلتا الحالتين وأعتقد أنه بالنسبة
للغالبية في
البلد ،  إن مغادرة البلاد
ليست هناك وبالتأكيد ليست
مثالية للبلد
ولكن قادة الناس يتبنون
موقف الهجرة
إلى مكان أفضل إلى مستقبل أفضل
أعتقد أنه في كل
مكان فرصة وإثارة
ولم يكن ذلك ممكنًا  في الماضي
بدون ريادة الأعمال ولكن الحديث اليوم
عن الهجرة
نحن نعيش في وقت به الكثير من
الخطاب المناهض للهجرة وقد نسميها
رهاب المهاجرين ما هي الرسالة التي
ترسلها إلى المجتمعات التي لا تزال
تخشى المهاجرين جيدًا.
في الولايات المتحدة التي تعرفها ، انتهى بي
المطاف
بالمجيء إلينا من أجل تعليمي ، لكنني
نشأت دائمًا مع المثل الأعلى
في كوننا بوتقة تنصهر وأحب
هذه الفكرة كثيرًا بمعنى أنه في
حين أن الثقافات والأعراق تجعلنا
مختلفين أه نحن  بحاجة إلى محاولة الحصول على
قواسم مشتركة
وإلا فإننا ببساطة
سنحكم عليهم باستمرار من
خلال اختلافاتنا وليس من خلال
مساهماتنا وأعتقد أن هذا
هو المعيار الذي يتم  ga ضائعًا قليلاً
في الولايات
المتحدة وآمل أن يتعافى بمرور الوقت
وفي كل مكان آخر أيضًا أعتقد أن
المهاجرين
المهاجرين يصنعون البلدان
وأعتقد أن البلدان التي لا يوجد بها أي
مهاجرين
غالبًا ما تتدهور إلى حد ما بمرور الوقت لذا
أعتقد أننا بحاجة  لكي أكون في
الطرف المتلقي للأشياء ،
أعني أن أنظر شابيل ، سأخبرك
بحقيقة شخصية وذاكرة
كانت قوانين الهجرة في لبنان
لدرجة أن والدي الذي هاجر إلى لبنان
لم يتمكن من الحصول على جواز سفر لبناني
لأنه لم يولد هناك.
ولدت في لبنان بدون
جواز سفر لبناني لأن والدي
لم يولد هناك ، فهذه قوانين
غامضة يجب استبدالها
بحيث يمكن لأي شخص يريد الهجرة
إلى لبنان أو أي بلد آخر
أن يفعل ذلك مدركًا أن هذا هو
ما سيؤدي إلى استمرار البلد.
متجدد ولأن
الأشخاص الذين يأتون إلى مكان ما
يجلبون معهم الأمل والعزم
والشهية للمخاطرة ، فإن الأشخاص الذين يغادرون
مكانًا يأخذونه في مكان آخر
لذلك هناك شيء ما  الأشياء التي يجب علينا القيام بها
أيضًا
للانفتاح قليلاً على هذا بالطبع ،
هناك مخاوف لأنه
إذا جاء اللاجئون ولم تستطع الدولة
دعمهم
ولكن علينا أن نكون ماهرين في
الحديث عن لبنان ،
فأنا أعلم أنك ما زلت تتحدث قليلاً  من
أرنب ، هذا صحيح ، دعني أختبرك
اليوم ، من
الصعب جدًا القيام بذلك بالنسبة لي في بيئة رسمية
في المرة القادمة عندما أكون في قاعة الموسيقى ،
يمكنني تناول مشروب أو اثنين يمكنني التحدث
معك
قبل إغلاق هذه المقابلة  هل يمكننا أن
نعرف ما هي الخطوات
التالية للقاح ، والآن يجب أن تتم الموافقة عليه من
قبل إدارة الأغذية والعقاقير
وبعض السلطات الطبية أيضًا ، نعم
في كل دولة بشكل رئيسي ، يتعين على
السلطات التنظيمية
مراجعة الملف وبمجرد
الموافقة عليه ، يتم توفير الإمدادات
نبدأ في الحدوث
ونأمل أن يحدث هذا بالفعل بحلول
نهاية العام إن
شاء الله
، إن شاء الله ، أخبار رائعة وإن شاء الله سنعود إلى
الشرق الأوسط قريبًا
للزيارات وربما لمزيد من
الأعمال المستدامة.  قل على
المدى الطويل ولرؤية الأصدقاء
والعائلات الذين أخبرهم أنك
فخور جدًا بك بالطريقة التي
كنت تتحدث بها عن المدينة في المنطقة لفترة من
الوقت ،
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي تدور جميع التقارير الإخبارية
النجاح الكبير الذي حققته في
دبي بخصوص موديرنا ونحن
فخورون حقًا بكل هذه الإنجازات ،
لذا شكرًا جزيلاً لك على وقتك
ونأمل أن نراك مجددًا قريبًا جدًا ، شكرًا
لك [موسيقى]